now joe biden has just put out a
commercial trying to turn the tables on
you on the question of
football let's watch it good weather by
opening day standard we are going to be
in the 60s
enjoy the game and now to honor america
please join in the singing
[Music]
why is football so important especially
for
the the big ten all these moms players
want them to play and then they're not
able to play are they safer playing
than not it shows you the lie of the
democrats i'm the one that says play
football
i said they're young strong people
they're not going to have a problem with
covid or
the china virus or whatever you want to
call it i'm the one
and they didn't like my narrative so
they just made up in there because if
you look
michigan is closed all of these states
that are closed north carolina is closed
these states that are closed are run by
democrats and the reason they're closed
is because we have an election
on november 3rd and they don't want the
opening of the states and they don't
want the income they want to keep it
nice and close
but you take a look at what the states
that are closed it's terrible what
they've done
and those people and you know you
discuss it a lot so do i
there's a lot of death depression uh
drug addiction
on the other side when you keep it
closed
i think you're losing more people than
it's terrible what you're doing to
people
than when you open it so
i'm the football guy i'm the one that
wants to have football
i put it out all the time i'm very upset
with big ten big ten they should have
opened it
but i'm the one that wants the football
everybody knows it
they saw that and they said trump didn't
these people
just you know they have players suing
now to play and their parents are really
upset michigan state
penn we'll look state ohio state
they could have been the national
champions this year ohio state
absolutely and there are
a number of them in that category but
look at pennsylvania
you have a democrat governor you have a
democrat in north carolina you have a
democrat in michigan they're all
democrats
those are the states and i do believe
the governors are telling those colleges
we don't want it yeah that's an
important point for americans to
understand you think that the governors
are putting their foot down saying uh
the sec they're going to try to play
you know acc is playing but no way
political mr president is this political
the governor of pennsylvania the
governor of michigan the governor of
north carolina
they control those teams directly or
indirectly because they have to you know
so much money so much aid
so many other things including traffic
signs and everything else that they have
to give
those governors control those schools
it's all done by democrats
but just to show you how how they lie
and how they cheat
and the biggest problem you have i want
football back by the way
are you watching i want football okay
joe biden doesn't even know football
joe biden look joe doesn't know he's
alive but let's see how it all turns out
okay
let's see how it all turns out it's a
very sad thing i will say this
we have tremendous potential we closed
it up we're opening it up we're doing
record numbers as you saw
over nine million people employed now
over the last three months it's a record
of the history of our country
we have a chance of having one of the
best years we've ever had next year
unless somebody comes in and wants to
raise your taxes put back on regulations
you know i'm not sure i gave the biggest
tax decrease in the history of our
country and we're going down lower
but i'm not sure i think that the
regulation cuts that i did which were
the biggest in the history of our
country
might have been even more important than
the tax cuts you said that joe biden
is china's candidate to win they want
him badly but you said well
at your rnc speech he said oh i know
that but i'm not going to tell you why
without
compromising national security
tell us a little bit more about that
well number one uh
you look at a son walking away with a
billion and a half dollars joe
is is he doesn't even criticize john
i've never heard him even criticize
china
he was the one that said oh china is
wonderful china is this china is that
china's not the enemy they're not the
problem
i've taken billions and billions tens of
billions of dollars out of china
he's taking the tariffs off that's for
sure china oh the tariffs are going to
come off we're taking in billions of
dollars on tariffs
that would destroy us because it gives
them such an unfair competitive
advantage no we're taking in billions
they don't want me
i get along very well with president xi
although i must tell you since the
covet situation i have not exactly been
talking to them too much could you make
them
pay for that well we they are paying a
lot now but how could they pay
specifically
what they've done to us in terms of the
death of people and i'm not talking
about justice i'm talking about the
world
you can never pay for that what they've
done to this country what they've done
to the world
you can never just in terms of death
economically at some
point maybe you can catch up but you're
talking about a lot of good trade deals
i made an unbelievable trade deal they
and frankly they ordered more corn last
week than any time at any time in the
history
of this country are they taking
advantage of this pandemic with
what they've done to hong kong what
they're trying to do in the philippines
maybe choking off some of the south
china sea are they taking it
i think that i think that they're hurt
much worse than people think they're
having a very hard time in china china
is going very bad inside the real
numbers their manufacturing they say
has gotten back to par it's not and
they're doing very poorly china is doing
very poorly
and they lost tens of thousands of
people they lost more than any other
country they just don't report it
you know how do you import everything
and by the way i saw a statistic come
out the other day
talking about only six percent of the
people actually died from covet which is
a very interest
that they die for uh from well they had
comorbidities which you've gotten
criticized for
because there are comorbidities as the
italians showed for every kova death
i think of 70 something percent had two
or three comorbidities
but the covet might ultimately have been
the key morbidity to hit them but
bottom line but it's an interesting
statistic mr president you're still
having fun
doing this i'm having a good time
because we're doing a job like
just about nobody else has ever done and
and i said it before i'll say it again
and nobody even challenges me on it i
this administration despite all of the
fake
russia russia russia and hoaxes and
impeachments
we've done more in this administration
than any president
in the history of our country if you
look at our military's rebuilt
if you look at choice for the vets and
if you look at accountability for the
vets and i protected the second
amendment
which by the way if they got in your
second amendment is
gone your taxes are tripled your second
amendment is gone
your religious liberty forget it they're
keeping the churches closed
on purpose you have churches that still
aren't open but you're allowed to go to
a casino
it's a terrible thing that's happening
because a lot of people don't know how
funny you are but you're one of the
funnier people that i know
but you're also in a very serious time
so this is a very serious this isn't
time for games and you know if people
say g he's
come comes across as a little bit rough
or a little bit direct i don't have time
not to be i really don't have much time
not to be
we have to get things done and we're
getting them done like no president
has ever despite the obstruction because
they are obstructors despite the
tremendous obstruction
we're getting them done like nobody's
ever done before and that makes me happy
mr president it's always great to see
you thank you so much